bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi en séance
l'examen d'une proposition de loi
présentée par le groupe socialiste
le texte élargit la compétence des juges
français aux infractions les plus graves
c'est à dire à celles qui sont visées
par le statut de la cour pénale
internationale
il s'agit de permettre à ses juges
français de poursuivre et de juger des
génocides des crimes de guerre et des
crimes contre l'humanité alors que ces
actes n'ont pas été comique dans le
territoire français la loi du 9 août
2010 qui est adapté de droit français à
l'institution de la cour pénale
internationale avait déjà élargi la
compétence territoriale des juges
français mais cette extension était
alors subordonné à plusieurs conditions
comme par exemple l'obligation que le
faits soient punissables à la fois dans
le droit français et dans la législation
du pays où les faits avaient été commis
c'est pourquoi pour l'auteur de la
proposition jean pierre sueur
il faut aller encore plus loin et
supprimer ces verrous et donc supprimer
les conditions actuellement posées par
la loi de 2010 je suis donc direction
l'hémicycle pour l'examen de ce texte
très bonne après midi à tous sur public
sénat l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
tendant à modifier l'article 6 190 89
tirs et 11 du code de la procédure
pénale relatives à la compétence
territoriale du juge français
concernant les infractions visées par le
statut de la cour pénale internationale
présentée par monsieur jean pierre sueur
et plusieurs de ses collègues dans la
discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur
jean pierre sueur du groupe socialiste
l'auteur de la proposition de loi et
président de la commission des lois pour
une durée de 20 minutes monsieur
président pietro
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues nous sommes réunis cet
après-midi pour débattre d'un sujet
majeur pour la france pour tous les pays
du monde et pour l'espèce humaine parce
que l'histoire nous a appris l'histoire
ancienne l'histoire contemporaine
l'histoire récente que les horreurs font
partie hélas de l'expérience humaine et
que nombreux sont hélas ceux qui ont été
les auteurs de crimes contre l'humanité
de crimes de génocide de crimes de
guerre les victimes des milliers
dizaines de milliers centaines de
milliers millions d'êtres humains
face à cela la civilisation les
civilisations l'humanisme
la détermination de celles et ceux qui
sont ici et j'en suis sûr sur tous les
bancs devrait pour que lorsque l'on
entend ou lorsque l'on dit plus jamais
cela ce ne soit pas un voeu contredit
bien vite trop vite les chers collègues
chacune et chacun d'entre nous a
présentement à l'esprit ces horreurs et
notre humanité qui a connu tout cela a
connu aussi des trésors de civilisation
d'intelligence de sensibilité d'amour
d'altruisme et c'est ce qui a fait que
peu à peu
après les procès de nuremberg de tokyo
peu à peu la conscience s'est éveillée
et plus que l'as conscience encore
l'action des démocrates ont fait en
sorte qu'il y ait une cour pénale
internationale et ce matin même notre
collègue rapporteur alain anziani
faisait remarquer qu'il avait fallu 50
ans pour qu'existe une cour pénale
internationale on aurait pu penser
qu'après les procès de nuremberg et de
tokyo
très vite une telle instance serait
instaurée il a fallu du temps
toujours est il
que cette date de 1998
cette date de la convention de rome qui
a donné naissance à la cour pénale
internationale est importante parce que
mes chers collègues il ne s'agissait pas
seulement de créer une institution
nouvelle la cour pénale internationale
mais il s'agissait par la convention de
rome en instaurant la complémentarité
entre eux les tribunaux des différents
pays signataires et entre ceux-ci et la
cour pénale internationale
il s'agissait d' unir les justices du
monde entier la justice pour que le
droit s'instaure partout et ce droit
devrait devait comprendre
bien entendu le châtiment nécessaire des
auteurs des crimes contre l'humanité des
crimes de génocide et des crimes de
guerre notre pays a tiré les
conséquences de la convention de rome et
de la création de la cour pénale
internationale dans sa constitution
d'abord et puis par le vote d'une loi du
9 ou 2010 qui permet aux juges français
de connaître de ces crimes
mais il est apparu dès le vote de cette
loi et même avant que celle ci était
infiniment restrictives et qu'il me soit
permis à cette tribune de rendre hommage
à toutes celles et tous ceux qui se sont
battus qui se sont mobilisés pour que
l'on change cette loi et c'est ce qui
m'a conduit à présenter le 6 septembre
dernier avec beaucoup de collègues
socialistes mais je sais que des
collègues de tous les groupes politiques
partagent ce sentiment
cette proposition de loi mais si j'en
suis le premier signataire ma dette et
notre dette à nous qui l'avons signé ea
nous qui participeront au débat et je
l'espère voterons ce texte
notre dette est immense à l'égard de
robert badinter à l'égard de madame
delmas marty à l'égard de la coalition
qui s'est créé et de son président simon
foreman à l'égard des parlementaires qui
se sont beaucoup impliqués et je veux
citer à cette tribune notre collègue
patrice gélard pour faire avancer les
idées faire avancer le droit sur cette
question tellement importante
alors vous savez que la loi veut du neuf
ou 2010 à réformer l'article 689 11 du
code de procédure pénale et que cette
loi et sa traduction dans le code de
procédure pénale se traduit par un
certain nombre de restrictions qu'on a
appelé d'ailleurs verrous
premièrement pour que les juridictions
françaises puissent être compétente et
puisse donc poursuivre et puisse donc
condamnés il fallait que l'auteur des
crimes où l'auteur présumé des crimes
réside habituellement sur le territoire
français comment ne pas citer de robert
badinter qui s'est toujours élevé contre
cette formulation et je le cite
conserver la condition de résidence
habituel signifie que nous ne nous
reconnaissons compétent pour juger les
auteurs des crimes contre l'humanité
c'est-à-dire des pires qui soient que
s'ils ont eu l'imprudence de résider de
manière quasi permanente dans notre pays
penser que ces personnes viendraient
chez nous habiter dans leur pavillon
entouré de thuya et irait jouer au
tiercé régulièrement le dimanche est une
absurdité
on sait bien que si on pose cette
condition là alors on choisit
l'impuissance et vous savez aussi que
dans nos textes de droit
il est constamment indiqué qu'il suffit
de se trouver en france pour pouvoir
être poursuivis jugés condamnés
donc la première restriction qui est
absurde c'est celle là il faut que et il
suffit que la personne se trouve sur le
territoire français tel est le premier
point de cette proposition de loi
le second c'est de mettre fin à ce que
ce qui est appelé la double
incrimination de quoi s'agit-il
pour poursuivre
d'année jugé un auteurs présumés de
crimes contre l'humanité il faudrait
selon la loi française actuelle que les
faits soient punis par la législation
française bien sûr mais aussi dans les
mêmes termes par la législation de hull
et à le ou les faits ont été commis ou
encore de l'état dont l'auteur présumé a
la nationalité et il faudrait de
surcroît que cet état soit parties à la
convention de rome
très franchement ces conditions sont
difficiles à réunir
on ne comprend pas pourquoi ces
conditions sont posées
je rappelle par exemple que la cour de
cassation
dans son jugement du 23 octobre 2002 à
considérer s'agissant de la convention
sur la torture que la juridiction
française était fondée à exercer une
compétence universelle
quand bien même il y aurait eu dans
l'état où les faits se sont produits ou
dans l'état dont l'auteur présumé a la
nationalité une loi d'aministie voter
c'est dire que la cour de cassation a
parlé à ce sujet avec une grande clarté
j'ajoute qu'il serait choquant de
subordonner la possibilité de poursuivre
et de juger les auteurs des crimes les
plus odieux
elle existe à l'existence de
dispositions pénales de l'état dont ils
ont nationale la nationalité ou bien où
ils ont commis ces crimes
à cet égard vous me permettrez
d'ailleurs
de souligner l'apport de notre
rapporteur qui tout à leur expliquera la
position qui est la sienne et les
amendements qu'ils nous proposent par
rapport à ce texte
en effet il est clair je viens de
l'expliquer qu'il faut mettre fin à
cette double incrimination mais de
surcroît il n'est pas juste
il ne serait pas juste et il faut aller
plus loin que cette proposition de loi
telle que je les ai écrites que ne
puisse être poursuivi que les personnes
relevant de pays signataires de la
convention de rome est ce que nous
propose notre rapporteur par
l'amendement qui arrive au début du
texte et qui a été intégrée dans le
texte de la commission
c'est de dire ici au sénat de la
république française que les
juridictions françaises auront
compétences sur tous les pays de la
terre qu'ils aient signé ou qu'il n'ait
pas signé la convention de rome et c'est
important parce que il y à des tyrans il
y à des personnages criminels qui
naturellement dispose d'une justice aux
ordres et d'une juridiction sur mesure
et qu'ils n'ont pas commis l'imprudence
entre guillemets de souscrire à la
convention de rome
eh bien il faut que la justice puisse
passer par rapport à ces états là et par
rapport surtout aux personnes qui
seraient soupçonnés de crimes contre
l'humanité de crimes de génocide et de
crimes de guerre le troisième la
troisième restriction est relative à ce
qui est présenté comme étant le principe
de primauté de la cour pénale
internationale
en effet il est demandé pour que la
juridiction française puisse assumer son
office que le ministère public s'assure
préalablement auprès de la cpi qu'elle
décline expressément explicitement sa
compétence et vérifie de surcroît
qu'aucune autre juridiction
internationale ne s'est saisi de la
question
nick aucun état n'a demandé
l'extradition de la personne susceptible
d'être concernée c'est absurde
pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit et disons le
clairement d'une interprétation erronée
de la convention de rome
le statut de rome et c'est d'ailleurs en
quoi il est un texte essentiel pose le
principe de la complémentarité entre la
cour pénale internationale et les
juridictions nationales
il n'instaure en aucun cas une primauté
et d'ailleurs on peut y voir eux un
indice fort dans le fait que s'agissant
de la cpi
il est prévu de lui de la saisir des
situations je cite
s'agissant des je vais diction au
national il est prévu de les saisir
d'une personne c'est donc comme l'a
montré et je le cite encore une fois
robert badinter aux états qu'il revient
au premier chef de poursuivre et de
condamner s'il ya lieu
les auteurs de ces crimes c'est
seulement faute pour ces états d'agir
que la cour pénale internationale
interviendra
par conséquent cette troisième
restrictions qui existe aujourd'hui dans
notre droit est contraire à l'esprit
même de la convention d'europe reste mes
chers collègues une quatrième
restrictions dans la proposition de loi
j'ai proposé que l'on mette en cause le
monopole du parquet cela a donné lieu
mes chers collègues vous le savez à de
nombreux débats et la commission a
beaucoup travaillé et bien entendu je
partage les préoccupations de la
commission du rapporteur
je souligne d'ailleurs la richesse des
débats que nous avons eus aussi bien
avec les associations tout
particulièrement la coalition que j'ai
cités tout à l'heure même si nous
n'avons pas adopté toutes ses positions
avec les représentants des magistrats et
bien sûr madame le ministre avec votre
vous même votre ministère avec aussi le
ministère des affaires étrangères
d'autres ministères
cela nous a amenés à prendre en
considération ce qui s'est passé dans un
certain nombre de pays tout
particulièrement la belgique et
l'espagne a évité des recours dilatoire
ou d instrumentalisation de la justice
et à trouver un chemin que viendra vous
décrire dans un instant alain anziani
ce faisant nous avons la volonté d'être
fidèle aux principes qui sont les nôtres
de rompre avec ce qui existe aujourd'hui
dans le dans notre droit c'est-à-dire
des restrictions excessives à commencer
par la première celle de la résidence
habituelle et de trouver un chemin qui
soit fondée à la fois sur l'efficacité
de la justice et sur le réalisme qui est
nécessaire par rapport à un certain
nombre de situations qu'on
m nous ne prétendons pas que la solution
qui sera apportée où les dispositions
qui seront mises sous les eaux vote ici
aboutissent à fermer le débat
nous sommes en première lecture et nous
croyons au débat parlementaire à la
force du débat parlementaire sur un
sujet aussi important
la seule chose que je demanderai c'est
que bien entendu on aille de l'avant
mais madame la ministre ce n'est pas
vous que je vais dire il faut aller de
l'avant sans vous nous montrez depuis
quelques semaines et quelques mois que
vous allez de l'avant et c'est toujours
plus porteur que eux de se complaire
dans les hésitations
vous me permettrez de vous le dire
puisque nous avons l'honneur de vous
accueillir cet après midi mais pour
aller de l'avant il faudra premièrement
que ce texte arrive rapidement à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il revienne et
que l'on puisse mener ce travail dans de
bons délais je crois que c'est
indispensable
deuxièmement il y a plusieurs lois
constitutionnelles qui sont en
préparation et dont j'ai entendu parler
madame le garde des sceaux et tout
particulièrement une loi je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il faille faire jeunes ici une
appréciation personnelle une seule loi
qui comprendrait beaucoup de ceux qui
par leur aide beaucoup de sujets qu'ils
aborderaient beaucoup de sujets une loi
sur le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui fonderait tant par les
conditions de nomination que de
promotion la dépendance du parquet
français serait aussi importante par
rapport au débat que nous allons que
nous avons cet après midi
voilà je pense mes chers collègues que
si vous voulez bien l'adopter
ce texte consiste constituera
d'indéniables progrès par rapport à l'un
des sujets les plus importants peut-être
qu'il nous soit donnée d'aborder ici la
défense de l'humanité par rapport aux
criminels qui commettent qui ont commis
ces horreurs qu'ils doivent être jugés
c'est une nécessité pour la conscience
humaine que sont les crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes de génocide et les
crimes de guerre je vous remercie
dans la discussion en général la parole
est à monsieur alain anziani rapporteur
de la commission des lois
monsieur le président madame la garde
des sceaux
mes chers collègues nous posons
effectivement cet après midi une
question très importante
faut-il ou non accepter l'impunité
faut-il accepter l'impunité parce que
l'effet se déroulerait dans un pays qui
politiquement matériellement
militairement n'aurait pas la capacité
de conduire des poursuites contre les
auteurs de crimes contre l'humanité de
crimes de génocide ou encore de crime ou
de délit de guerre la réponse d'ensemble
au delà même de ses infractions que je
viens de citer a été donnée maintenant
depuis quelques temps et je reprendrai
les propos de notre président de la
commission après la guerre il est vrai
avec la conscience universelle a
progressé et que nous avons institué à
la fois tribunal de nuremberg est à la
fois le tribunal de tokyo pour juger des
crimes eux qui ont un retentissement
universel qu'est l'on veut qualifions
les de cette nature mais voilà c'est
vrai qu'il nous a fallu 50 en un demi
siècle pour progresser toujours plus
vers une justice pénale internationale
50 en un demi siècle pour nous
apercevoir que après la seconde guerre
mondiale il y avait encore des crimes
contre l'humanité ou des crimes qui
avait aussi une valeur universelle
il a fallu donc attendre et c'est le
rôle de l'assemblée générale des nations
unies d'avoir initié à ce moment là à la
fois un tribunal pour le rwanda est un
autre ensuite pour les crimes commis
dans la r yougoslavie en même temps
c'était l'urgence il fallait y répondre
mais dans le même mouvement
nous avons également où à l'époque
l'institution internationale a pensé
qu'il fallait aussi envisager la
création d'une cour pénale
internationale sami un peu plus de temps
et ça me même quelques années à tel
point que la cour pénale internationale
ne fonctionne que depuis 2002 mais une
fois que cette cour pénale
internationale a été posée tout n'était
pas réglé il ya une innovation majeure
de la cpi de la cour pénale
internationale
c'est d'admettre qu'elle n'a qu'une
compétence complémentaires j'oserais
presque dire subsidiaire et qu'au fond
d'une façon très réaliste
elle admet que ce qu'elle ne pourra pas
couvrir d'autres juridictions nationales
pourrons à ce moment là engagé voire
engager des poursuites et donc à leur
tour couvrir ces infractions qu'elle
n'aura pas les moyens matériels mans
nous connaissons malgré d'ailleurs la
forte contribution de la france la
situation de la cour pénale
internationale mais d'autres à fond là
pouvons engager des poursuites pour des
faits de nature qui relèvent de la cour
pénale internationale
à mon tour je voudrais comme a dit jean
pierre sueur salué le rôle de notre pays
dans cette institution de justice pénale
internationale et en particulier qui ne
le ferai pas je pense que d'autres le
feront encore tout à l'heure ça lui est
évidemment l'action très énergique de
robert badinter qui a été un véritable
croisés contre l'impunité et qui a
conduit ce combat avait beaucoup de
fermeté tout ça aboutit à quoi il
fallait ensuite que notre droit s'adapte
à cette nouvelle donne internationale
cela a mis une dizaine d'années mais là
aussi je voudrais à mon tour salué le
rôle qui a été celui du doyen gélard
dans la loi d'adaptation du droit
français
un cour pénale internationale du voyage
est là mais également d'ailleurs de
françois zocchetto qui n'est pas là pour
l'instant qui a aussi beaucoup si j'ai
bien lu les comptes rendus des débats de
l'époque beaucoup oeuvré pour aboutir à
une solution avec la loi du 9 août 2010
voilà mais il est vrai que avec le recul
nous nous apercevons que cette loi du 9
août 2010 n'est pas satisfaisante
elle n'est pas satisfaisante sur les
quatre points soulignés par notre
président tout à l'heure je ne les
reprendrait pas évidemment sur les
quatre verrous c'est l'expression
consacrée ou les quatre conditions de
recevabilité
je ne les rappellerai pas alors jean
pierre sueur a proposé à feu déposé
cette proposition de loi qui propose de
supprimer ces 4 0 les auditions que j'ai
eu l'honneur de conduire depuis quelques
semaines pas suffisamment teilleur ça
c'est un problème du travail
parlementaire
nous sommes toujours trop pressé en tout
cas les conditions que j'ai eu l'honneur
de conduire ont visiblement conclu à un
consensus pour supprimer les trois
premiers verrous et je n'en parlerai pas
il reste une question en débat quand je
dis en débat c'est un débat entre nous
ici à l'intérieur du sénat en débat
aussi à l'extérieur du sénat ou plus
généralement du parlement nous le savons
bien
et cette question elle est simple à
formuler difficile à résoudre comme
souvent simples la formule 1 qui aura le
droit d'engager des poursuites
et là nous voyons bien deux points de
vue qui correspondent à deux logiques
différentes et toutes les deux sont
honorables la première logique qui est
portée par des associations des ong des
mouvements de droits de l'homme nous dit
pourquoi voulez vous appliquer à ces
questions d'extraterritorialité un droit
différent que aux questions qui relèvent
ou infraction qui relève du droit sur
notre territoire est de 10 nous avons
une tradition il suffit il suffit de
l'appliquer
moi je crois je parle franchement que
nous ne devons pas minimiser je pèse mes
mots mais le caractère hors du commun de
ces infractions d'extraterritorialité me
fais ton ne me faites pas dire que c'est
une législation d'exception mais il ya
un caractère hors du commun
pourquoi hors du commun mais tout
simplement parce que nous avons un temps
et un lieu de l'infraction profondément
différent de ce que nous connaissons
habituellement le temps de l'infraction
est différent des infractions de droit
commun puisque là nous avons un temps
qui est marqué par l' imprescriptibilité
cela veut dire que vous pouvez
poursuivre quelqu'un pour des faits d'il
ya une cinquantaine d'années
c'est évidemment un caractère hors du
commun et vous pouvez poursuivre pour
des faits qui n'ont pas eu lieu en
france avec tout ce que cela peut
nécessiter comme capacités de
surveillance de recensement denquête
mais qui ont pu avoir lieu à des
milliers de kilomètres quand je dis
deymier kilomètres ça peut être des
dizaines de milliers de kilomètres c'est
le propre de la définition de la
compétence universelle
donc nous ne sommes pas dans le droit
commun et c'est la raison pour laquelle
une des raisons pour laquelle je crois
qu'il n'y a pas lieu a mécaniquement à
appliquer nos règles de procédure pénale
mais trouve que cette explication que je
donne n'est pas suffisante et gens
préfèrent une autre qui va écarter
toutes questions de théorie de doctrine
et qui va simplement s'en remettre à
l'expérience
lorsqu'on est législateur la première
chose que nous devons faire c'est
regarder ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
de chez nous et voir quelles sont les
expériences qui ont pu être conduite
dans d'autres pays
il ya ceci de particulier que la france
est déjà particulière dans sa procédure
pénale puisque c'est l'un des rares pays
il n'y a que trois en europe qui accepte
que l'action publique soit mise en
mouvement par la victime lors d'une
plainte avec constitution de partie
civile n'y a que trois pays la france
je vais donc pour l'instant de côté la
belgique et l'espagne est un mot sur
chacun de ces pays la belgique la
belgique nous a produit une loi qui
évidemment lorsqu'elles étaient publiés
ne pouvait qu'en chanter tous ceux qui
se préoccupent des droits de l'homme et
nous sommes tous occupés par des droits
de l'homme ça a duré quatre ans la
belgique a commencé par dire
il n'y a quasiment plus de conditions la
belgique avait été très loin puisqu'elle
vmm supprimer la protection qui naît de
l'immunité elle s'est fait condamner
pour sa dette
elle avait supprimé toutes conditions
liées au territoire belge et elle avait
gardé sa tradition judiciaire qui permet
effectivement une victime de poursuivre
sans passer par le biais du ministère
public
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé il sait pas
c'est que vous avez eu des plaintes
d'origines différentes parfois croiser
l'une contre ariel sharon l'autre contre
il essaiera rafat d'autres évidemment
contre les représentants des états unis
contre bush senior en particulier se
passer ça quatre ans plus tard après pas
mal d'incidents
les etats unis disant écoutez si on ne
peut plus aller à bruxelles
parce que nous sommes susceptibles de
connaître des poursuites ou même plus
puisque les poursuites ne peuvent être
engagées même sans présence sur le sol
puisque nous pouvons plus aller à
bruxelles
nous n'irons plus jamais mais donc le
siège de le temps évidemment ne peut pas
rester à bruxelles
et puis l'ambassade d'israël évidemment
aussi rapatrier son ambassadeur et
d'autres pays ont
testez y compris d'ailleurs les
palestiniens donc voilà la situation qui
la suggestion belge provoquée par
l'absence de filtre je le dis quatre ans
plus tard la belgique a renoncé à son
système est revenu un système où le
procureur fédéral filtre les plaintes et
dans laquelle il est aujourd'hui
nécessaire aussi d'avoir un lien avec le
territoire belge
donc c'est aujourd'hui un système plus
fermé que le système français
il ya également l'exemple espagnol
l'exemple espagnol est d'une nature un
peu différente mais des espagnols aussi
ont voulu faire une loi très large
quelques années plus tard ils sont
revenus de leur générosité
entre guillemets et aujourd'hui vous
pouvez effectivement en espagne engager
des poursuites
simplement à la requête de la victime
mais encore faut-il que soit une des
victimes soient de nationalité espagnole
soit l'auteur soit de nationalité
espagnole soit qu'il ya un lien
suffisant et fort je me trompe pas c'est
bien l'expression fort entre l'espagne
et l'infraction et on voit donc que
l'espagne aujourd'hui amis d'autres
conditions de recevabilité
je pense que on ne peut pas rester sourd
on peut pas se mettre la main devant les
yeux en disant mais non tout ça est faux
mais non ça c'est la réalité c'est
l'expérience ah bon et nous législateurs
nous sommes responsables évidemment de
la législation que nous allons produire
voilà pour l'examen de cette proposition
de loi présentée par le groupe
socialiste et qui vise à élargir la
compétence territoriale des juges
français aux infractions les plus graves
c'est à dire à celles qui sont visées
par le statut de la cour pénale
internationale
vous pourrez évidemment la revoir à tout
instant sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à vous sur public
sénat